i am here to speak
for all generations to come i am here to
speak
speak on behalf of the starving children
around the world whose cries go unheard
i'm here to speak for the countless
animals dying across this planet
because they have nowhere left to go
i am afraid to go out in the sun now
because of the holes in our ozone i'm
afraid to breathe the air
because i don't know what chemicals are
in it
i used to go in i used to go fishing in
vancouver
my home with my dad until just a few
years ago
we found the fish full of cancers
a generation ago i was that 12 year old
child
in 1992 i had five minutes to speak to
the un's earth summit
in rio de janeiro my friends and i had
started an environmental club
and we'd traveled to this huge
international meeting
about environment and development to
tell the adults
they had to change their ways that same
year
1700 scientists would issue the world
scientists
warning to humanity to tell us
that humans and the natural world were
on a collision
course much like greta tunberg and her
peers today
we believe that decision makers should
be acting on science
and facts and the facts were telling us
that we were headed for ecological
collapse
all this is happening before our eyes
and yet we act
as if we have all the time we want and
all the solutions
back then climate change had been
identified
but we had yet to really feel it today
almost 30 years later climate change is
no longer a prediction
it is here and it happened far faster
than even the experts predicted
we did not stop it today the work
that we must do is about mitigation
trying to limit how bad it gets in 2015
in paris the world agreed to limit the
planet's warming to one and a half
degrees celsius
as beyond that would pose too great a
threat
to human life to meet this
we will have to cut our global emissions
by half
in the next 10 years
i'm only a child and i don't have all
the solutions
but i know i want you to realize neither
do you
young people are always at the front
lines
of any revolution and it's young people
who ask me what did your speech actually
do
why didn't the delegates actually listen
well looking back i think that the
delegates of the conference actually
did listen not just to me but to the
thousands of
voices calling for change if you look at
the declarations the documents that came
out of rio
they are radical they include
the un's framework convention on climate
change
set up to stabilize greenhouse gas
concentrations in the atmosphere
and prevent dangerous interference with
the climate system
23 years before the paris agreement
154 countries signed this
legally binding international agreement
i'm only a child yet i know we are all
in this together
and should act as one single world
towards one single goal
so why didn't the world take action
instead governments focused on growing
the economy
on business interests and of course
winning the next election
it shows a crisis in human governance
where our political systems make it
impossible
to act in long-term interests for the
people
and future generations today it's 2020.
we have the momentum we have the paris
agreement to limit
the earth's warming we have youth and
social justice demands
we have calls for divestment we have
calls for climate emergencies
we have the science we have the
solutions
and we all are experiencing climate
change
we are at a moment parallel to rio
now is the time to take action
if you don't know how to fix it please
stop breaking it how do we ensure that
this time
we act on our words history has shown us
that in moments of crisis society
can truly transform we've seen this in
times of war
in times of economic collapse and in
times of disease
today we live in the time of covet 19.
we've seen governments and institutions
across all sectors
working quickly working together
humans like to think that we're in
control of everything
but we have been reminded today that the
laws of nature
are the true bottom line we've been
reminded that science
and expertise are crucial to our
survival
coveted 19 has shone a light on inequity
and revealed our prejudiced
infrastructures
it is a warning if we don't listen
if we don't change next time could be
far worse
my dad always says you are what you do
not what you say well
what you do makes me cry at night
you grown up say you love us but i
challenge you
please make your actions reflect your
words
that last sentence summarizes my entire
speech at rio
please make your actions reflect your
words
today i'm a mother i have two little
boys
parents i'm speaking to you
our generation is determining the lives
of our children
we have 10 years where we can still make
a difference
we have 10 years to cut our emissions by
half
the way to truly love our children is
to make our actions reflect our words
now it's time to get to work
thank you